[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
limoges il ya huit ans j'ai rencontré
payons un cheval pas n'importe lequel
fallait-il encore le savoir à l'époque
je cherchais un nouveau compagnon de
route un animal capable de venir avec
moi sur les scènes de tous les opéras
travers le monde
le cabaret des spectacles mais également
la compétition
je cherchais un cheval blanc gris un
cheval lumineuses sont des pistes
parfois bien sombre et je n'ai pas
trouvé
alors un jour on me dit il y à celui ci
il n'est pas facile
vous avez beaucoup de points communs il
y en avait aussi des positifs nerveux
anxieux jaloux peyo je ne cache pas que
la première année a été horrible un
point où j'avais discrètement remis en
vente pendant neuf mois 9 mois où je
comprenais pas ce cheval pourquoi
pourquoi aussi agressif parfois jaloux
anxieux pourquoi est-ce que je
n'arrivais pas communiquer avec lui et
puis au bout de neuf mois une visite
d'achat
quelqu'un vient le voir et me demande de
le monter bien sûr j'ai soupiré ne
voulant plus le voir j'ai quand même
présenté peyo monte et ce jour si je me
rappellerai toute ma vie c'était un en
juillet j'ai lâché prise
je ne voulais plus le voir je voulais
plus de ce cheval alors je vais
simplement mis dans le rouge je suis
monté dessus a cru et je vais demander
d'avancer
et pour la première fois ils avaient
obéi puisse arrêter puis tournez pu
galoper sans mettre par terre et ce jour
là j'ai compris que le problème ce
n'était pas lui
c'était moi et quand je parle comme ça
ça se mérite et l'année d'après nous
avons été champions de france l'année
suivante également nous avons enchaîné
écumé les cabarets le music-hall des
lieux magiques à la rencontre des gens
toujours aussi incroyable
dix mille kilomètres par mois beaucoup
de voyages par avion mais toujours la
question de savoir pourquoi est ce que
ce cheval était différent des autres
pourquoi est ce qu'ils n'aiment pas être
attrapé être câliné pourquoi est ce
qu'ils n'aiment pas le con s'approche de
lui qu'on entre dans sa bulle pourquoi
ce qui tient tout le monde la distance
et qui à un moment donné vous ne savez
pas pourquoi lui va vous traîner jusqu'à
se diriger s'orienter sur une personne
bien précises à force on s'aperçoit et
on comprend que c'est toujours le même
type de personne même profil clairement
affaibli moralement physiquement
psychologiquement
et puis des exemples je me souviens une
fois à la fin d'un gala au moment des
photos un enfant qui s'approche de nous
pour faire une photo est payé au coin
cet enfant sur son poitrail sous sa
gorge et qui commença à jouer avec ses
cheveux jusqu'à lui enlever sa perruque
s'en est suivi encore d'autres cas et
puis n'étant ni médecin ni vétérinaire
je me suis dit peut être qu'il était
temps de partager l'expérience
peut-être que j'étais fou peut-être
qu'il était fou peut-être que nous
sommes fous tous les deux mais ça valait
quand même le coup de se rapprocher de
neurologues psychologue psychiatre avant
de dire mon animal est spécial mon
animal comprends mon animal
comme pouvons tous le faire avec des
animaux mais ici c'était clairement
différent on s'est aperçu rapidement que
beyou était capable de détecter les
tumeurs les cancers prévenir également
des fins de vie ce qui a rassemblé
environ 150 chercheurs médecins
spécialistes
une quarantaine de vétérinaire et bien
sûr pendant quatre ans nous avons étudié
avant d'être aujourd'hui devant vous non
plus grand secret à hauteur de 15
accompagnement 15 fin de vie tous les
mois
quinze décès qu'il faut accompagner dans
la dignité des enfants des adultes des
moments forts des moments privilégiés de
la vie et je me suis aperçu que l'être
humain
en plus d'être qui avait de pire pour
l'humanité était réellement intéressant
malheureusement à partir du moment où il
se sait condamné par la maladie
c'est dur à dire mais on ne triche plus
face à la mort c'est le seul moment de
la vie également où nous sommes tous
égaux
la mort c'est une fatalité
il a été important pour nous de conjurer
le sort de faire en sorte que l'humanité
devait prendre la place et que les
conditions de m optimale pour partir
décemment dignement accompagner ce
cheval le cheval incroyable qui
passionne aujourd'hui le corps
scientifique fédère toujours plus bien
sûr on ne prend pas un cheval et on le
met on ne veut pas du jour au lendemain
à cheval dans un hôpital
et puis un animal n'a rien à faire dans
un établissement de santé
ici c'est son choix alors il est lâché
après avoir suivi un protocole sanitaire
il est tendu des parasites et non pas
parce qu'il est cheval mais parce que le
danger des deux à l'hôpital
c'est l'homme le cheval ne transmet rien
à l'homme alors après avoir suivi un
protocole sanitaire
il est lâché dans les couloirs et
avons isolé cinq angles de recherche la
gériatrie la pédiatrie la psychiatrie
les soins palliatifs et alzheimer une
vie passionnante
rien ne prédestinait à vivre cela rien
ne prédestine et non plus à mettre ma
vie de côté et à me mettre au service
d'un animal et non pas l'un vers ce et
accompagner toujours plus a rencontré à
fédérer à porter les enfants dans les
bras jusqu'à ce que tout s'arrête dans
l'amour la dignité et mettre toute cette
expérience là au profit la science pour
vous pour moi pour nos parents nos
grands parents nos enfants nos
petits-enfants pour essayer de
comprendre pourquoi est ce que nous
arrivons à diminuer les anxiolytiques
les morphiniques pourquoi est ce que
nous arrivons à pallier à des situations
marque parfois tragiques où nous n'avons
pas de solution encore autant de
questions qui nous observons tous les
jours c'est la première fois que je
viens
un événement accompagné de peyo je suis
heureux que ce soit ce soir à limoges
beaucoup de choses à vous dire beaucoup
de cas incroyable et cette expérience
pour qui venait du milieu des strass
paillettes a fait naître en moi une
réelle vocation
rien ne prédestinait à l'époque il ya
cinq ans j'avais donc 25 ans à être
confrontés à la mort tous les jours
apportez à soutenir mais finalement
c'était ça aussi ma place aujourd'hui
j'ai une vie incroyable bien sûr c'est
lui et moi on avance pour l'humanité
pour la dignité humaine
une expérience incroyable bien sûr
peut-être que nous retrouverons un
nouveau pays et peut-être pas mais au
moins nous l'avons vécu des projets
plein la tête
la création d'un centre de dignité
humaine pour la première fois créer une
structure à mi chemin entre les soins
palliatifs et la maison pour que les
gens puissent partir dignement
accompagnés
prendre en charge et vivre vivre parce
que les quinze derniers jours de la vie
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire
sont des jours où la joie encore sa
place et où les gens ont besoin de vivre
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]